a suspect who drove a car into a parade
of children in wisconsin was out on bail
thanks to the left's criminal justice
strategy and after kyle rittenhouse's
acquittal the media doubled down on
their lying narrative i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news and
just moment and unfortunately there is
plenty of news first let's remind you
that black friday is coming up but
here's the thing you don't have to wait
to black friday to start saving today
you probably should start saving by
switching over your cell phone coverage
for example from one of the big carriers
over to puretalk usa you can actually
cut your cell phone bill in half by
switching over to pure talk pure talk
gives you a killer 5g coverage on one of
the largest 5g networks in the country
and still saves the average family over
800 a year i made the switch the
coverage is excellent their us-based
customer service actually cares about
you and pure tax prices again pretty
much wholesale unlimited talk text six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
you can keep your number you can keep
your phone or this month you can get
black friday prices on new phones like
the iphone 12 for just 479 they have a
30 day risk free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose head on
over to puretalk.com shop for the plan
and phone that's right for you then
enter promo code shapiro and you'll save
50 off your first month and save on a
new phone that is puretalk.com
promo code shapiro puretalk is simply
smarter wireless some restrictions apply
see site for details head on over to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you enterprise save 50 off
your first month and save on a new phone
alrighty so the big news of the weekend
is this horrific incident in waukesha
wisconsin according to the uk daily mail
at least five people have been killed
and 40 injured including at least 12
children
after a speeding suv plowed into a
christmas parade taking place in a
suburban town near milwaukee on sunday a
red ford escape broke through barriers
in waukesha wisconsin around 4 40 p.m as
the parade was taking place drove at
speed through crowds sending bodies
flying his horrified families watched on
helplessly we're not going to show you
the video because it really is pretty
horrific and it doesn't add anything
here you can just see kids marching down
the street and then this ford suv which
you can't really
you have no idea why it's there just
plowing through people apparently some
gunshots were fired as well police
originally said a person of interest was
in custody no arrests had been made
chief daniel thompson said no motive had
been established but the officers are
not discounting it terrorism officers
are also looking into the possibility
the suspect was fleeing an earlier
incident involving a knife when he
reached the parade which would be
unbelievable if this guy was involved in
a knife crime and then was running from
the cops and decided hey while i'm at it
i may as well run over a few school
children truly an act of evil thompson
said one officer fired at the vehicle in
an unsuccessful bid to stop it with
witnesses saying it sped along the
parade route and did not slow down even
as it hit a schoolgirls dance troupe and
elderly members of the walking dancing
grannies along with families sitting by
the side of the road
dozens of pieces of footage ended up
capturing the carnage revealing that the
car traveled at least three blocks down
the parade route before breaking through
barriers and speeding away a picture
captured later in an unknown location
showed what appeared to be the vehicle
involved backed onto a driveway with the
hood badly dented and bent up it's
unclear how the vehicle came to be there
police have not revealed exactly how the
suspect was arrested
just horrific all the way through and
there's lots of speculation at this
point about the motive of this person
about whether this person was in fact
involved in an earlier crime that day
i don't on this show talk about the
identities of mass shooters or mass
killers or terrorists i do talk about
who they are and what they did but i
don't reveal names on this show because
we don't wish to inspire copycats or
give attention to some of the worst
people on earth what we do know at this
point
is that this person does have a criminal
record he's a 39 year old black male
from milwaukee county a felon and
apparently according to wisconsin right
now milwaukee their court system
suspended his speedy trial rights due to
court congestion they released him on
500 bail even though he was facing a
serious weapons and other felony charge
then even though he was stalked with a
string of new felony charges he was
released again on 1 000 bail three days
before the parade massacre
this guy has a rap sheet as long as your
arm milwaukee county has a really long
backlog of criminal cases and because of
bail reform this notion that if you are
poor you should not be held in jail
because you can't pay the bail so
instead we'll release you onto the
street for a minimal amount of money
like a thousand dollars now you have
criminals who are back walking the
streets and this is a perfect case in
point of that
according to judge mary triciano
we've taken this pandemic very seriously
as well we should including the variance
we're being very careful this is with
regard to the backlogs and the and the
unwillingness to keep people in jail
so a lot of people who have been
committing crimes again are back out on
the streets
on social media the suspect apparently
showed animus toward police
posted on happiness about the kyle house
verdict as well as george floyd's death
quoted at malcolm x we don't have a full
motive at this point what we do know is
that this person should not have been on
the street
apparently the department of justice
criminal record history includes many of
these arrests arrested in 1999 for a
carry concealed weapon charge
in 1999 he was also arrested for
aggravated battery felony that was
dismissed concealing carrying a
concealed weapon non-criminal
disposition not reported in 2000 more
arrests for aggravated battery felony
convicted probation
resisting misdemeanor dismissed cocaine
possession misdemeanor 2002 resisting
non-criminal taken drive vehicle without
consent habitual criminal felony
dismissed no prosecution 2003 resisting
misdemeanor convicted 2005 resisting
misdemeanor receiving stolen property
misdemeanor dismissed possessed stolen
possessed controlled substance dismissed
2009 paternity warrant non-criminal
resisting officer non-criminal resisting
misdemeanor convicted 2010 felony
strangulation and suffocation domestic
abuse amended complaint filed convicted
misdemeanor battery dismissed criminal
damage to property dismissed 2011
probation violation felony hold for
probation authorities extradition
request disposition not reported
resisting convicted thc possession
paternity warrant possessed with intent
to deliver thc convicted bail jumping
convicted there's only up to 2011 by the
way there's still another 10 years on
this guy's record ago
2012 probation violation turned over to
probation authorities bail jumping
felony no prosecution failure to appear
multiple bail jumping misdemeanor two
counts no prosecution resisting no
prosecution extradition possess a thc
felony case dismissed 2020 firearm
convicted of out-of-state felony charge
issued possession of meth dismissed
endangering safety domestic abuse
reckless use of firearm charge issued
paternity warrant non-criminal
hey again this is according to wisconsin
right now so this guy has a rap sheet
that just goes on forever forever and he
was out on bail on a thousand dollars
bail
after having been arrested like three
days beforehand for bail jumping
so the strategy apparently in in
milwaukee county is somebody jumps bail
if you capture them you should have them
post bail which they will then jump
makes perfect sense but this is brought
part of a broader prosecutorial strategy
that the left has imposed
on major cities across the united states
you want to know one of the reasons why
we've seen a major uptick in crime in
major cities across the united states
over the past few years it's because
prosecutorial strategy has changed
dramatically
it's because people like george soros
have poured millions of dollars over the
past seven eight years into electing
left-wing prosecutors across the country
we'll get some more of this in just one
moment first let's talk about a simple
fact you need a great sofa in your home
you do so you have a great mattress
already because you listened to me right
and you bought a helix sleep mattress
well now helix has gone beyond
mattresses and now they are making sofas
they have a new company it's called all
form they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door so what makes an all form sofa
really cool well for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize the sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost of traditional stores you can
pick your fabric it is spill stain
scratch resistant the sofa color the
color of the leg sofa size and shape
make sure it's perfect for you and your
home they've got arm chairs and love
seats all the way up to an eight-seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can always start small and
buy more seats later on if you want your
all form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move all form sofas are
also delivered directly to your door in
the past if you wanted to order a sofa
you need to hire somebody to come and
put that thing together but i've done it
myself it's really easy to put the all
form together it is super comfortable we
have a three seat sofa with chase in the
sand color with espresso legs it sits in
our bedroom right now
if getting a sofa without trying it in
stores sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry get 100 days to decide if
you want to keep it more than three
months and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you a full
refund they also have a forever warranty
literally for the rest of time all form
is offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at
allform.com find that perfect sofa today
all form dot com slash ben that's all
form.com
ben so remember this sort of activity
has been championed by the left
prosecutions prosecutors letting
criminals out of jail
jeffrey toobin who used to be more
famous as a legal commentator now he's
more famous for not being able to keep
his junk in his pants
he wrote a piece in 2015
for new yorker magazine called the
milwaukee experiment what can one
prosecutor do about the mass
incarceration of african americans quote
like many people in the criminal justice
system john chisholm the district
attorney in milwaukee county has been
concerned for a long time about the
racial imbalance in american prisons the
issue is especially salient in wisconsin
where african americans constitute only
six percent of the population but 37
percent of those in state prison
according to a study from university of
wisconsin-milwaukee as of 2010 13 of the
state's african-american men of working
age were behind bars nearly double the
national average of 6.7 percent
the figures were especially stark from
milwaukee county where more than half of
african-american men in their 30s had
served time in state prison
how chisholm wondered did the work of
his own office contribute to these
numbers could a da do anything to change
them
now this is the part that's amazing
right because this is the animating
philosophy behind so much of the
democratic party these days it's a
disproportionate number of people from a
particular group are in jail it must be
because the system is evil and corrupt
now here's the problem the result of
that sort of thinking means letting
criminals out of jail based on race and
class that's what it means it means that
if you wish to have fewer black people
in jail
you're gonna have to either identify
people who are innocent and shouldn't be
in jail or you're going to have to let
criminals out of jail and people who
supposedly need to be let out
on bail
after having jumped bail multiple times
which is apparently what happened in
this particular case in waukesha
chisholm decided to let independent
researchers examine how he used his
prosecutorial discretion
over several years chisholm allowed the
researchers to question his staff
members and look at their files the
conclusions were disturbing according to
the vera study prosecutors in milwaukee
declined to prosecute 41 of whites
arrested for possession of drug
paraphernalia compared with 27 percent
of blacks et cetera et cetera et cetera
so chisholm decided his office would
undertake initiatives to try to send
fewer people to prison while maintaining
public safety how's that going for you
over there john gone great for you is it
by the way if the case is that he's
letting too many white people off then
arrest more white people who are
criminals and put them in prison do not
let criminals out of jail nobody has an
interest in letting criminals out of
jail in order to quote unquote even out
the numbers
chisholm said that prosecutors should be
judged by their success in reducing mass
incarceration and achieving racial
equality
how it
excuse me
prosecutors should be judged on how the
crime rates go down that is the only
thing prosecutors should be judged on we
have an adversarial system to protect
defendants it is not the job of
prosecutors to determine
whether mass incarceration is a thing or
achieving quote unquote racial equality
in outcomes is a thing that's not the
prosecutor's job the prosecutor should
not be looking to wait we have too many
black people in prison i guess this
criminal who is black should not be in
prison because he's black that's insane
that's insane and there's a reason why
i've seen a spiking murder rate in
milwaukee over the last couple of years
chisholm's efforts have drawn attention
across the country
cyrus vance manhattan district attorney
said quote john is a national leader in
law enforcement because he is genuinely
interested in trying to achieve the
right results not only in individual
cases but in larger policy issues as
well chisholm reflects a growing
national sentiment that the criminal
justice system has failed african
americans
et cetera et cetera so this has been the
shtick
they stick for a very long time is that
is that prosecutors of the left are
doing a great job by evening out the
numbers that is the thing that that
means the most he said the racial
disparity spoke for itself starting with
the disparities in the state prison
system
but there were very significant
disparities in specific categories the
one that stood out the most was
low-level drug offenders possession of
marijuana drug paraphernalia things were
clear there were clearly a disparate
number of african-americans being
charged and processed for these offenses
he says when i first saw the data
i thought here is some good news
because apparently it said that we
charged white offenders for property
crimes at a higher rate than we do black
offenders for those kinds of cases i
thought good here's a disparity the
other way around but a deputy of mine
pointed out what the data really meant
was we devalue property crimes in the
censor city we don't charge a car theft
okay well that's right so then the
question is why are you not charging the
drug distribution cases why are you not
charging the felony bail jumping cases
it's just incredible so the the entire
basis for criminal justice in wisconsin
has been rooted apparently in this
michelle alexander new jim crow if too
many black people are in prison it's
because america is racist philosophy as
opposed to you're a prosecutor lower the
crime rate by arresting criminals who
committed crimes again if you want to
make the case these people are innocent
if you want to make these cases these
people shouldn't be in jail make the
case they shouldn't be in jail but you
can't make the case they shouldn't be in
jail when they are criminals
and you shouldn't be allowing them to
roam the streets ramming cars into
children because you want to establish
racial equity
are you insane
again the murder rate in wisconsin is
out of control
by the way milwaukee police have only
solved like 58 of homicides last year in
2020 compared to 68
in 2019 the rate thus far this year in
milwaukee is 34
their murder rate is out of control
there are 190 homicides in milwaukee
last year
okay but this is supposed to be a big a
big win
for
this prosecutor
insane
according to the medical college of
wisconsin
there have been 941
victims
in homicides by firearm homicides by
non-firearms or non-fatal shootings in
wisconsin in 2020 okay that is a jump
from 542 in 2019
so
really well done and here's the problem
this is a national strategy okay this is
not just in milwaukee it's not just in
waukesha okay this is a national
strategy by the left
you can see it happening we'll get some
more of that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that there are
10 million job openings but only about 7
million unemployed job seekers so if you
are a person who's seeking to hire you
really need to make sure that your job
gets seen by the right people employers
are having to go above and beyond to
entice people to want to work for them
they're offering pet insurance and legal
services and providing identity theft
protection well if you're trying to grow
your team and you're having trouble
hiring you need to use zip recruiter
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire
ziprecruiter uses powerful technology to
find and match the right candidates up
with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site in the united states based on g2
ratings zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the very first
day right now you can write zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address ziprecruiter.com dailywire
that ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter dot com
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire which is why
we've been using it here at daily wire
for years okay so as i say this is a
broad strategy by the left okay and it's
financed by people like george soros i
know that the media want you never to
say george soros's name because it's
supposedly anti-semitic to point out
that george soros funds wild left-wing
causes he does okay i'm an orthodox jew
i can say whatever the hell i want about
george soros george soros
is a left-wing fanatic and he has spent
billions of dollars on various left-wing
causes around the globe
he is a very bad man he does very bad
things and left celebrates him for it
politico reported back in 2016 quotes
george soros's quiet overhaul of the us
justice system
quote while america's political king
makers inject their millions into
high-profile presidential and
congressional contests democratic mega
donor george soros has directed his
wealth into an under the radar 2016
campaign to advance one of the
progressive movement's core goals
reshaping the american justice system
the billionaire financier has challenge
has channeled more than three million
dollars into seven local district
attorney campaigns in six states over
the past year a sum that exceeds the
total spent on the 2016 presidential
campaign by all but a handful of rival
super donors
his money has supported african american
and hispanic candidates for these local
powerful roles all of whom ran on
platforms sharing major goals of sorrows
like reducing racial disparities and
sentencing directing some drug offenders
to diversion programs instead of to
trial it is by far the most tangible
action in a progressive push to find
prepare and finance criminal justice
reform-oriented candidates for jobs that
have been held by long-time incumbents
and serve as pipelines to the federal
courts
andrea du steele president of emerge
america a candidate training
organization for democratic women says
the prosecutor exercises the greatest
discretion and power in the system it is
so important
there's been a confluence of events in
the past couple of years all of a sudden
the progressive community is waking up
to this soros has spent on d.a campaigns
in florida illinois louisiana
mississippi new mexico and texas this is
as of 2017. through a network of
state-level super pacs and a national
527 unlimited money group each named a
variation of safety and justice
each organization received most of its
money directly from soros
and again this is not just in blue
states this is in red states as well
this is how you see left-wing
prosecutors in places like florida
left-wing prosecutors in places like
louisiana
and this stuff has some pretty
predictable effects you know why it's
happening
okay you know why the crime rates are
going up in a wide variety of areas
again fast forward 2021 is an article
from july of this year quote politico
four wealthy donors fuel overhaul of
california's criminal justice system
the social justice movement has never
lacked for energy last year's police
killing of george floyd sparked waves of
support for blm progressive donors in
recent years have strategically targeted
prosecutor races in major cities because
district attorneys wield power over
sentencing and investigations in
california social justice advocates are
preparing to defend the state's top
prosecutor attorney general rob banta
who is closely aligned with the reform
movement and was one of the nation's
most liberal ag's
the last 10 years has been the biggest
shift i've seen in terms of
philanthropic interest in this issue
says lenoir anderson who heads
californians for safety and justice when
you have that shift the door is open
because you're with the winds have
changed
in california few causes get far without
a pile of money ford's owners paddy
quillen quinn delaney elizabeth simons
and caitlin krieger channeled 22 million
dollars for criminal justice ballot
measures and allied candidates the
previous two years their campaign
contributions have steadily increased
each election cycle they spent 3.7
million dollars alone to elect george
george gascon who wrote the social
justice wave that swept over america
last summer
to unseat incumbent laga jakey jackie
lacy in november
gascon by the way has then proceeded to
completely wreck the city of los angeles
even worse than it was by failing to
prosecute criminals
quillen is a philanthropist and the wife
of netflix ceo reed hastings simons is a
former teacher and daughter of hedge
fund billionaire and philanthropist
james simons krieger and her husband
instagram co-founder mike krieger
running criminal justice nonprofit
okay and of course george soros has
given some money here as well
in 2018 an organization funded by soros
supplied the most money for the
california d.a races
and by the way this is exactly how san
francisco ended up with
chase abouten in san francisco
right bowden is a wild left prosecutor
in san francisco
and because bowdoin is wild left you end
up with scenes like this so over the
weekend 80 looters simultaneously broke
into a nordstrom near san francisco
here's a little bit of the video
take a look behind me you can see some
of the doors and windows of that louis
vuitton store smashed glass littering
the sidewalk several streets surrounding
union square had to be blocked off and
still are according to a police source
this began as a smash and grab then
turned into a robbery a little after 8
pm spoke to one witness who says that
more than a dozen people could be seen
running out of the store clinging to
merchandise and hauling as much as they
could
at one point sfpd officers could be seen
surrounding a gray convertible mustang
with one patrol car blocking it several
officers taking their batons to smash
out the windows source telling us that
at least one person inside that car had
to be taken to the hospital
okay so people just showing up at louis
vuitton just robbing the place just like
taking the entire place down
according to the washington post drivers
blared their horns saturday evening as
dozens of thieves carrying luggage and
bags started from a nordstrom department
store near san francisco and hopped into
cars waiting for them outside all but
three of the 80 or so looters escaped
police said two store employees were
assaulted one was pepper sprayed by the
intruders according to officers in
walnut creek that's a city about 25
miles east of san francisco
the spectacle saturday night was one of
several incidents of looting and
shoplifting reported at high-end retail
stores around the bay area over the
weekend
so the friday night louis vuitton hit
that was in union square on sunday night
officers in hayward about a 30-minute
drive from san francisco we're
investigating after a group of smash and
grab burglars destroyed glass cabinets
and stolen merchandise from a mall
jewelry store
san francisco d.a chase a bowden right
one of these lefties elected by george
soros's money said these crimes are
happening around the bay and across the
country i stand in partnership with our
local regional state and federal
partners as we work together to do
whatever it takes to keep you safe
except for arresting criminals and
keeping them in jail because we
obviously wouldn't want an unequal
number of black and white people in jail
forget about who's committing the crimes
the only thing that matters is that we
have an equitable distribution of
convictions that's the only thing that
matters and by equitable they mean
equitable to the racial population not
equitable to the amount of crime that's
being committed
so here's the question how many people
have to die for the equity vision really
how many criminals have to be put out on
the streets because of the vision of
equity because of the lie that if too
many people of one particular race end
up in prison because too many people of
one particular race are committing
crimes this is because the system itself
is racist you can make the argument
there's too much crime in particular
demographics because of history and the
racism of history but making the
argument the system itself is
responsible right now for too many black
people looting louis vuitton is
ridiculous
it's ridiculous on its face and it ends
with more crime and more people being
harmed particularly by the way more
people in the black community is a
generality
now there are consequences to the
narrative the left puts out and those
consequences are incredibly dire
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
truth okay the simple truth is that you
need to sleep at night so i got to admit
got some stuff going on right now that's
uh keeping me awake at night but when i
finally am able to calm down enough to
sleep it's mainly because i have a great
set of sheets i am talking about bull
and branch this cyber week bowling
branch is offering their best deal of
the entire year if last night's sleep
was not incredible their sheets will
make all the difference with bowling
branch you get the best sleep of your
life with their highest quality organic
cotton treats these sheets are so good
that once i got bowling branch you can't
go back i literally took all of our
other sheets and i threw them out when
you shop bowling branch during cyber
week you're supporting a family-run
business that crafts the highest quality
toxin-free pure organic cotton bed
sheets they are fantastic husband and
wife team scott and missy tannen founded
bowling branch to create a new standard
in betting by doing the things the right
way not the easy way their signature hem
sheets those are the all-time bestseller
they're beloved for so many reasons like
how they got softer with every single
wash this every week give your loved
ones the best sleep of their lives or
treat yourself with bowling branch
their holiday packaging and famously
soft sheets blankets pillows and more
make a difference everyone will feel get
25 off from november 23rd through
december 2nd with the best offer of the
year at bullandbranch.com that's 25 off
at boll and branch.com exclusions may
apply alrighty so meanwhile it is it is
part of this broader narrative that the
left has has suggested that everything
they don't like in america is due to
racism which means the cure is never
going to be a cure just as the problem
of too many people going to jail in the
black community is not a problem of the
system itself being racist it is a
problem with too many people committing
crimes it turns out a great way to avoid
jail is not to commit crimes i know this
is really really difficult and complex
stuff
but
suffice it to say if you don't smash and
grab at louis vuitton you're not going
to get arrested for smashing and
grabbing in louis vuitton as a general
rule yeah none of these prosecutors are
letting people off because they think
they're innocent they're letting them
off because they believe that there are
too many black people in prison
which is unjust okay justice has to be
done on the basis of what you do not on
the basis of what a prosecutor feels
about the state of play with regard to
racial disparities in the united states
but that's exactly these narratives have
consequences and you can see those
narratives forming and being reified in
real time with regard to things like
kyle written house so last week powell
written house gets acquitted on friday
afternoon
that is a a correct criminal justice
decision it happened because kyle
rittenhouse
was not guilty
he committed
the acts that he did in self-defense
that is perfectly obvious
but the media responded to written
house's acquittal by suggesting that it
was once again evidence of more
deep-seated american racism of course of
course of course it always is by the way
ignoring other cases that were happening
in the country that demonstrate
precisely the opposite so for example
i hear a couple of cases that i'm sure
you did not hear about over over the
weekend
so there's a man named andrew coffey iv
same weekend
he was found not guilty on all accounts
of murder and attempted first degree
murder
is in vero beach florida
coffee is a black man he was accused of
firing at indian river county sheriff's
deputies during an early morning drug
raid at his home back in 2017. his
girlfriend alteria woods was caught in
the crossfire shot 10 times and later
died coffee was charged with the murder
of woods after a grand jury exonerated
two law enforcement officers for her
death
before the case went to the jury's hand
coffee took the stand to defend himself
he blamed the deputies for his
girlfriend's death the defense said that
coffee was asleep and thought the
flashbang was gunfire so he fired his
gun because he thought he was under
attack
he said i was trying to protect me and
alteria i thought i was doing that i
feel i didn't protect her i can't sleep
with that they killed her
the prosecutors said deputies did
announce they were there they say coffee
then fired at the deputies and they
returned fire
coffee was found guilty on account of
possession of a firearm by a convicted
felon
which could have a penalty of up to 30
years in prison but he was found not
guilty in the murder of woods
the indian river county sheriff eric
flowers released a statement saying it's
disappointing that jury did not see the
tragic death of alteria woods occurred
as a direct result of the actions of
andrew coffey iv again apparently what
happened is that they announced
themselves he got up he fired at the
cops and he shot his girlfriend in the
process and he was not convicted of that
but he's he's black i was informed in
the united states this means that he
would definitely go to jail especially
if he was innocent
him meanwhile again
same weekend a white missouri police
detective was found guilty on friday in
the death of a black man who was fatally
shot in 2019 as he sat in a pickup truck
outside his home
judge jay dale young ruled that the
detective eric j de val canary of the
kansas city police department had no
reason to go to the property of cameron
lam 26 he was shot twice as he was
backing into his garage on december 3rd
2019. the detective and another
detective had driven to mr lam's house
after receiving a report about a traffic
accident involving a truck that that
lamb was driving they didn't have a
warrant they didn't have reason to
believe a crime had been committed when
they rushed into lam's backyard and
confronted him
the prosecutors also suggested that the
police had planted evidence at the scene
to make it look as if lam had a gun
the judge rejected the detective's claim
he believed lam was going to shoot his
partner and convicted the officer of
second-degree involuntary manslaughter
and armed criminal action that carries a
charge of three years in prison
the detective and his partner
he is white they said that he that they
were initial aggressors in the encounter
with cameron lam on december 3rd 2019
according to judge jones
and uh the detective was also suspended
without pay pending termination after
the decision of course
so
what happened to america is systemically
racist but the narrative must be
maintained because again if the
narrative is not maintained this might
mean that we might treat people as
individuals and we might jail criminals
and we might hold people accountable for
their own actions
and that the left hands have that
because they need to reshape all of
society along the lines that equity can
be achieved only by alleviating all
disparities even if those disparities
are due to individual actions that falls
disproportionately within groups
okay so the aftermath of the of the
trial happened over the weekend kyle
rittenhouse here is here is his reaction
to being acquitted last week
the jury reached the correct verdict
self-defense is not illegal
and i believe they came to the correct
verdict and i'm glad that everything
went well and it's been a rough journey
but we made it through it
hey meanwhile rittenhouse's attorney
said that if he had to do it again he
wouldn't go
everybody wants kyle to show some
contrition and say sorry
um
hindsight is 20 20.
and when i've talked to kyle if he had
to do it all over again
he wouldn't go there
but
that clock cannot be unwound
what happened happened and we have to
live
in the real world not what we wish
happened okay
so the important thing is the media
reaction to this because the media drive
the narrative and if that narrative is
that america is a deeply racist place
and every incident they will just lie
about in order to reinforce that
narrative that drives bad policy-making
decisions by the public because if you
believe that america is a deeply racist
place and that disparities in for
example criminal populations between
black and white are solely due to
american racism you're more likely to
elect a progressive prosecutor who puts
criminals back out on the street in the
name of equity
and the media are just botching the
story and they're not just botching it i
mean because remember this story is over
we've known all the facts in this case
for a year but we really know him now
because the case is over and we saw all
the evidence presented at trial by the
prosecution it doesn't matter the media
have their case and they're pressing it
forward and they are lying about it like
openly lying the detroit free press
said on sunday quote in august 2020
jacob blake was shot and killed by a
police officer in kenosha wisconsin he's
not dead
the hell are you talking about that's
not even true okay in the media are
repeating stuff like this
there's a paper in the uk that reported
that kylo ren has to shot and had shot
three black people all three of the
people he shot were white
meanwhile you have msnbc's tiffany cross
going on national television and calling
written house a quote little murderous
white supremacist
the fact that white supremacists roam
the halls of congress freely and
celebrate this little murderous white
supremacist and the fact that he gets to
walk the streets freely it lets you know
these people have access to instituting
uh laws they represent the legislative
branch of this country what are we to
make of that
well i hope that she enjoys the
defamation lawsuit that's what we ought
to make of that little murderous white
supremacist
she doesn't have
every word that she says there is untrue
he is not a white supremacist and he is
not a murderer by the law so i hope that
she really enjoys her summons for the
for the defamation lawsuit for the
subpoena that that'll be that'll be fun
to preserve all of her papers and all
this meanwhile cnn's van jones says we
now have a pattern of white vigilantes
again the narrative must be upheld at
all costs it is very important for the
left to uphold this narrative
this idea of
white vigilante violence is something
that we have to wrestle with and it may
not be
be done in one single court case but
we've got a pattern now
where white men feel that they have the
right to enforce the law themselves when
you look at a mod arbory
when you look at this case
when you look at trayvon martin when you
look at the white mob that attacked the
capitol that somehow
there is a group of people that think
that they have the right to take the law
into their own hands they can leave
their home with guns and they can
enforce their vision of the law on other
people
he was not enforcing his vision of the
law on other people he literally shot
these people in self-defense he was
attacked okay but the narrative has to
be maintained that it's white
vigilantism that's white racism white
supremacy amber ruffin who had never
heard of until she started being pushed
on twitter
she apparently has a show on peacock
which i guess is nbc's online wing and
and here she goes
it's not okay
for a man
to grab a rifle
travel across state lines
and shoot three people and then walk
free
it's not okay for the judicial system
to be blatantly and obviously stacked
against people of color
it's not okay
for there to be an entirely different
set of rules for white people
but uh i don't care about kyle
rittenhouse i don't care about that
racist judge and i don't care about how
that jury must be uh white people have
been getting away with murder since time
began i don't care about that i care
about you
and uh i can't believe i have to say
this but you matter
okay this sort of rhetoric is uh is
horrifying it's horrifying because it's
a lie so first of all he didn't cross
state lines of the gun second of all he
didn't just shoot people
third the people he shot were white
fourth self-defense is a defense that
applies to everyone black white and
green
fifth the notion that she doesn't care
about kyle rittenhouse is obviously
untrue she's crying about it on national
tv so no
but again this is the narrative the
narrative is
any story can be twisted to fit this
narrative that america is a white
supremacist country and therefore you
have to give power to radicals in order
to
in order to fix the problem and this
bleeds over into every area of our
culture remember it is a wave okay so as
i wrote in my book the authoritarian
moment the authoritarianism is coming
from from the institutions it is coming
from the institutions the left only
wants to talk about january 6th this
notion the idea that the democracy is
about to be overthrown every major
institution in american life is lying to
you right now about cases like kyle
writtenhouse every major institution in
american life is lying to you about
criminality every major institution in
american life is willing to twist the
fact and falsify the fact and then to
penalize you if you refuse to go along
with it
to suspend you if you refuse to go along
with it to fire you if you refuse to go
along with it
you will be plunking that black lives
matter sign down on your lawn or you
will lose your job
you will definitely not express any
support for for a kyle rittenhouse's
defense
or you will lose your job
you will not maintain that america is
not systemically racist or you will lose
your job that is what these folks want
and they will lie to get what they want
and again it's every area it's not just
you know your your media which is of
course just a propaganda wing for the
democratic party
it's it's cultural figures like reese
witherspoon
i'm old enough to remember when the
spoon wasn't entirely politically insane
but now she tweets out crap like this
quote woke up this morning thinking
about every mother father sister brother
friend who's lost someone to senseless
gun violence in america and then there
was no justice for their pain this is a
disgrace justice for for whose pain
the child molester attempting to uh grab
a gun from a minor
or the guy trying to slam a skateboard
into the head of a miner or the guy
approaching somebody with a gun to shoot
him which one of those people reese hey
how about mark ruffalo this mark
ruffalo's just my god mark ruffalo
he tweeted out we come together to mourn
the lives lost to the same racist system
that devalues black lives none of these
three people were black none of them
they were all whiter than i am
we come together says mark ruffalo to
mourn the lives lost to the same racist
system that devalues black lives and
devalued the lives of anthony and jojo
who the f is jojo is he spot is jojo
referring to joseph rosenbaum a
convicted pedophile is he literally
referring to a convicted pedophile who
used the n-word that night and tried to
chase down a guy to kill him as jojo
maria shriver tweeted out i'm trying to
take a beat to digest the written house
verdict my son just asked me how it's
possible he didn't get charged for
anything how is that possible i don't
have an answer for him well first of all
he was charged with stuff he was then
acquitted
also your son is 26 at some point you
might want to tell him that he is
capable of turning on a television
um
also
are you maria trying to take a beat to
digest the written house verdict how is
it possible that he didn't get charged
for anything uh last i checked your name
is maria kennedy shriver
right like you're you are like you're
part of the kennedy family
right and you're and teddy
drove a woman into the drink and left
her there to drown and then sat in
senate for several terms so i'm gonna go
on this one
you might want to like yeah cool in on
this one
but again it's every area of the culture
jaylen rose covering the nba talking
about cal written house
we want to know why we're launching into
sports here at daily wire one of the
reasons we're launching into sports so
you have to watch garbage like this from
jaylen rose
here's the thing
the black lives matter protest
was actually taking place
because jacob blake was shot and killed
by police officers
jacob blake is alive
it's just incredible it's just
incredible and by the way again this is
all mirroring the democratic party
political position we'll get to that in
a second because that's what this is
really about it's about the political
hay that is to be made by lying about
these things
period end of story
we'll get to that in just one second
first
you know i've been working really hard
that means that i don't always have time
to go work out in the middle of the day
so it sometimes hits the evening i've
got the kids to bed i really need to get
a workout in but i don't have time to
schlep on over to the gym and this is
when my echelon comes in unbelievably
handy echelon brings the gym to you when
you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can really help to have
world-class instructors choreographing
classes music from your favorite artists
a community of hundreds of thousands of
people who can give you that extra push
echelon gives you that echelon is the
affordable way to get the workout
equipment workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music one of the things i
like about echelon again i like the
competition i think that it's it's a
great motivator to see how you're doing
in the class for example some of the
people are unbelievably good i mean i'm
not near the top of the class i'll say
that echelon's certified fitness
instructors are supportive engaging in
fun and they know how to get you moving
echelon has a full range of affordable
workout equipment including stationary
bikes smart rollers sleek fitness
screens an auto folding treadmill all
are connected to provide the echelon
experience right now for a limited time
podcast listeners get up to eight
hundred dollars off msrp to get this
exclusive podcast discount text ben to
eighty one eighty one eighty one again
text my name ben to eighty one eighty
one eighty one and up to eight hundred
bucks off msrp text ben 281 eight one
eight one message and data rates may
apply see terms for details alrighty if
you missed the sunday special this
weekend don't miss out you really should
check it out why because i was joined by
my own florida governor ron desantis
he's taken a firm stance against joe
biden's unconstitutional vax mandate
just like we did here at daily wire we
sat down to make sense of it all it is
truly worth the lesson desantis is the
most influential governor in the united
states at this point he is the living
rebuttal to the left-wing position on
everything from criminality to covid it
was a really i think fascinating
conversation and ron is really engaging
go check it out right now at
dailywire.com or on my youtube channel
ben shapiro dailywire members get access
to special bonus content from sunday
special episodes do not miss out join at
dailywire.com subscribe get 25 off with
code do not comply also if you've been
worrying about what you're going to get
your loved ones this christmas i have
the answer for you the daily wire merch
store it's here yes after six years of
me promising it would come the dailywire
merch store has arrived it is ready to
be explored that's right head on over to
dailywire.com shop to check out the
collection of let's go brandon tailgate
gear our poster collection of the
founding fathers drinking leftist years
and so so much more anyone can shop at
the dailywire store only dailywear
members can get special discounts up to
20 off members also receive access to
shop exclusive merch like the daily wire
leftist year's tumbler which holds more
leftist years than the average man knows
what to do with so head on over to
dailywire.com
shop to get a little something for
everyone on your list who loves brandon
and if you're not yet a member sign up
right now at dailywire.com subscribe
enter code dw35 you'll get 35 off your
membership and all the perks you
wouldn't otherwise that is a hell of a
deal 35 off a membership at
dailywire.com subscribe enter code dw35
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so all of this is a mirror for
the democratic intersectional coalition
politics remember for the democratic
party the biggest thing to know about
the democratic party over the last 10
years is that they believe in their
heart that 2012 is the coalition it is
the winning coalition in 2012 was a
coalition of racial minorities and
college-educated white liberals and
everybody else get out of the way that
was the 2012 barack obama coalition and
democrats ever since have been
attempting to see that coalition as
durable they've been attempting to
cobble that coalition together they
believe that that is the coalition that
leads them to victory after victory for
the rest of time there's only one
problem it hasn't worked out for them in
2016 they did really really poorly in
2020 they won
because donald trump was not
popular by the poll numbers but they did
not do great in the house and they
didn't do unbelievably well in the
senate and now they're about to get
their asses kicked in 2022 but they have
to keep doubling down on stupid they
must double down on the intersectional
coalition politics which means they're
going to continue to take cases like
kyle rittenhouse and they're going to
continue to trump it that america is
racist because of them now you got to
wonder a certain point why the left
keeps choosing cases that are bad they
do right they choose the jacob blake
case they just lie about it joe biden
and kamala harris both got in touch with
jacob blake and his family even though
jacob blake was an alleged rapist who
had resisted arrest with a knife
and they had they continued to claim
that michael brown was a innocent black
man who was shot by the cops for no
reason when eric holder's own zoj found
that's not the truth ferguson grand jury
found that's not the truth they pick
cases specifically where they are in the
wrong
because if they can make you believe
that they can make you believe anything
it really is what that is and what they
want is a is a loyalty test in your
brain and loyalty test goes something
like this
you know that the facts are not what the
left says they are you know it you know
they're lying but will you mimic their
talking points anyway
will you maintain their talking points
anyway if so then you are a member of
the cult and therefore off limits and
you've bought your freedom
and if you are unwilling to do that well
then they will come after you okay so
the dccc for example put out a statement
in the aftermath of the written house
verdict
and the statement is just insane okay
here's what their original statement
said quote it's disgusting and
disturbing that someone was able to
carry a loaded assault rifle into a
protest against the unjust killing of
jacob blake an unarmed black man and
take the lives of two people and injure
another and face absolutely no
consequences it is clear our legal
system has one set of rules for some
americans in very different standards
for others people are right to be
outraged their right to be outraged with
the violence that disproportionately
hurts people of color and the legal
system that fails to hold the violent
accountable okay you may notice can can
you spot the error here i mean there's
several but can you spot the error
go back to the first slide for a second
okay the the
the error is this okay in case you
missed it
unjust killing of jacob blake an unarmed
black man
um
not unarmed not dead
okay but got the narrative to preserve
okay then joe biden put out a statement
so joe biden's original statement about
the written house trial and he was asked
his instinct originally was well you
know the jury reached its verdict and
really it's none of my business which is
the correct instinct for the president
of the united states then
his people got to him and they said you
need to appeal to the intersectional
coalition you need to say that america
is racist mr president and joe biden
said
so he had just come out of a colonoscopy
where they had to remove his head from
his ass just so they could get get a
good look inside his colon and then he
immediately shoved his head directly
back up his ass and issued this
statement quote while the verdict in
kenosha will leave many americans
feeling angry and concerned myself
included we must acknowledge the jury
has spoken
i ran out of promise to bring americans
together because i believe that what
unites us is far greater than what
divides us i know we're not going to
heal our country's wounds overnight but
i remember i remain steadfast in my
commitment to do everything in my power
okay but here's the thing he promises to
unite us also he's very angry at a jury
verdict that is obviously correct joe
biden meanwhile you get kamala harris
saying well you know the verdict speaks
for itself it speaks for itself and what
you're supposed to take away from this
that the verdict is bad obviously
hey guys well it was a good trip and um
they have questions about the verdict
and the verdict really speaks for itself
as many of you know i've spent a
majority of my career working to make
the criminal justice system
more equitable and clearly there's a lot
more work to do
oh yeah by the way if you believe that
one i've got a bridge in brooklyn to
tell you that you work to make the
criminal justice system more equitable
you'll recall tulsi gabber finishing her
on that in a presidential debate by
pointing out that she'd locked up a hell
of a lot of black people while smoking
pot herself apparently and kamala harris
meanwhile yet the naacp president derek
johnson maintaining the lie he says that
kyle rittenhouse being let off is like
emmett till
it's like emmett till
a 14 year old black boy who was murdered
for not committing a crime in the racist
south
you have to be insane to make this
comparison but the left is insane
the jury pool question is a real
question that we must embrace in a way
in which we increase the number of
people who are registered to vote and
willing to serve on juries it was an
injustice this was worse than the emma
teal trial this was worse to so many
trials where we know for a fact
individuals committed murder and yet
they were not
uh brought to justice
wait uh
it's like emmett till
so who's i'm until in this little
analogy would that be the child molester
attempting to attack a minor or would
that be the the career criminal
attempting to attack a minor skateboard
or would be the guy who's approaching
with a gun like which one of those like
emmett till exactly like i love an
explication of this meanwhile al
sharpton who again the fact that al
sharpton is taken seriously in american
public life is evidence that america is
not only not systemically racist that if
it is systemically racist it's sometimes
in the reverse direction al sharpton is
a cretan and al sharpton is a is a man
who is responsible for some of the worst
racial conflagrations in american
history here's al sharpton talking about
this case saying vigilantes can kill
well i mean i guess it's at least he's
not outside of freddie's fashion mart
shouting about the jews so i guess that
that's an upgrade i suppose
they have said now that vigilantes can
go to protest and kill people
and say that they were defending
themselves which puts all americans
particularly those that want to protest
for whatever issue in danger
from el sharpton meanwhile corey bush
the blm congresswoman from missouri
she tweeted out the judge the jury the
defendant it's white supremacy in action
again he's not a white supremacist the
system isn't built to hold white
supremacists accountable he's not a
white supremacist it's why black and
brown people are brutalized and put in
cages while white supremacist murderers
walk free not a white supremacist you
like is she just asking to be sued here
i'm hurt i'm angry i'm heartbroken
meanwhile colin kaepernick
our analysis of any issue would not be
complete without the backup quarterback
who wore pigs on his socks to depict
cops sounding off here's colin
kaepernick who's benched for the
immortal blaine gabber because he's such
a talented talented sports figure he
tweeted out as well did colin kaepernick
about this situation
did we just witness a system built on
white supremacy validate the terroristic
acts of a white supremacist this only
further validates the need to abolish
our current system white supremacy
cannot be reformed yes white supremacy
means that you get paid millions of
dollars to be a complete
buffoon
on national tv
and you have a you have an entire series
made about you on netflix in which you
compare the nfl draft to slavery
by the way the only case i've ever seen
for tearing down our current system is
the fact that colin kaepernick is a very
wealthy person that is the only case i
can think of for why we should tear down
the system
seriously
but here's the thing this is all part
and parcel of a broader narrative right
the broader narrative as always
is that america is systemically racist
and that comes with consequences
okay so you know that the the entire
intersectional coalition
is predicated on the ideology of
intersectionalism which essentially
suggests that there's a hierarchy of
victimization in american life and that
people who are who are
members of multiple victim groups have
higher and better status to speak about
the issues than other people so at the
top of the victimology hierarchy right
now are lgbtq people followed by black
people followed by hispanic people
indian native americans are are
somewhere in there as well
asian americans depends on whether we're
talking about them as a member of the
coalition or that they're trying to get
into college if they're trying to get
into college then they're down at the
bottom of the intersectional hierarchy
with with white people uh jews down
there as well
you move up and down in the
intersectional coalition based on
whether or not you are successful in
american life the the less successful a
group is economically speaking
socioeconomically speaking the more they
are quote unquote victimized by the
system and if you're an individual from
one of those groups who is successful we
just don't consider you part of that
group anymore so if you are a
nigerian-american who is highly
successful in the united states you
don't count as black anymore or you are
white adjacent or something that is
according to the intersectional system
and the broader ideology here is the
democratic party platform america is
systemically evil america is
systemically racist all of its
institutions all of its institutions are
corrupt and terrible
so it is no surprise to see kimberly
crenshaw the founder of
intersectionality and person who coined
this term
in a law review article that actually
was not as crazy as her as her
ideology would later become
she uh she tweeted out
acquitted
all effing charges understand what this
means
well what it means for kyle written
house is that self-defense is still a
defense
if it also means that you're a bad
lawyer so you don't understand how
self-defense works but also you're just
a bad thinker because again the idea
from from kimberly crenshaw and company
is that america is systemically racist
and that's why kyle rittenhouse got off
for shooting three white guys
nicole hannah jones joined in senator
hannah jones has been championed as a
great american thinker which is insane
considering that again i just don't
think she's particularly smart i think
she's a very stupid person based on what
she tweets out on a regular basis i
cannot i can no longer
maintain the the lie that nicole hannah
jones is in any way a bright person she
tweeted out three weeks ago that we
dropped the a bomb on japan because of
the sunk cost fallacy like she's just
adult so she tweeted out quote in this
country you can even kill white people
and get away with it if those white
people are fighting for black lives this
is the legacy of 1619. so
the legacy of 1619 is apparently that if
you shoot an alleged child molester not
alleged convicted child molester who's
shouting the n word
that's the legacy of 16 19.
okay and then she goes further right
somebody tweeted back at her viola
liuzzo and james reeb can testify to
that said schwerner and goodman down the
line okay so now she's comparing the
people who attack kyle rittenhouse to
civil rights activists who were murdered
in the american south
during the civil rights movement
that's it and so kylo ren house can
shoot them because they were quote
unquote pro-black lives matter
okay this is the narrative
and by the way it's now being taught in
american schools as we all know this is
part and parcel of the entire critical
race theory project
carlos lozada over at the washington
post
says quote the 1619 project which is
written by
nicole hannah jones created by nicole
hannah jones it's a piece of
pseudo-history it is a lie
he says the 16-19 project started as
history now it's also a political
program
we're getting this now sir uh it's been
now since the beginning
it was always a political program but
says carlos lazada the new york times
celebrated 1619 project is as intriguing
for the second half of its title as for
the first what is the project of this
sprawling project what are not just its
principle objectives and messages but
also its underlying methods and
objectives for a work of journalism
grounded in the specificity of a single
date there's an elusiveness almost a
malleability pervading the effort well
yes that's that's the point they don't
want to be pegged down to exactly what
they're saying
but the new york times is pushing it
hard the new york times magazine special
issue published august 18th 2019. a
broadsheet edition appeared the same day
there's a podcast spin off a new lengthy
book version an illustrated children's
book remember it's not being taught your
kids they just made a children's book
for the adult
probably
says carlos lozada
together these elements form a powerful
and memorable work one that launched a
seismic national debate over the legacy
of slavery and enduring racial injustice
in american life
it is also a work with a variety of
competing impulses ones that at times
can confuse and conflict
this is evidence in the 1619 project a
new origin story a book that softens at
some of the edges of the prior magazine
collection but transcends its original
mission as a historical corrective
informing readers what they now must do
or else risk personal complicity in the
painful story they have just been told
that's the whole shtick that's the whole
shtick here is our narrative it is
filled with lies now believe it and do
exactly what we tell you or you are
complicit in the evils of the american
system
this is the whole thing the project's
broad sheet declares that the goal of
the 6019 project is to reframe american
history making explicit that slavery is
the foundation on which this country is
built
okay the new book version
offers a few interpretations of the
overall effort
nicole and jones tries to buy back the
idea that this is a soul history of
america
but she says it's still truer than the
history that we have known
okay but this is an activist it's an
activist angle it is all about activism
they're not trying to hide the ball here
they're making very clear that they want
you to do things right and the things
they want you to do are the things they
want you to do they want you to elect
progressive prosecutors in cities they
want you to socialistically redistribute
income they want reparations they want
you to believe that every disparity in
american life is rooted in a history of
american racism maintained by the
systems that currently
prevail in the united states
now again the the
the agenda here is absolutely clear
and they're not going to stop with the
agenda
and and it's not just by the way people
on the right who are noticing this john
mcquarter who is a member of the center
left i think it'd be fair to say writing
for the new york times he has a piece in
the new york times today i just don't
know how long john's going to last over
there the piece is called here's a fact
we're routinely asked to use leftist
fictions
and he points out that this is what the
left does they create fictions and then
they force you
to repeat them
he says
these days an aroma of delusion lingers
with ideas presented to us from a
supposedly brave new world that is in
reality patently nonsensical yet we are
expected to pretend otherwise to point
out the nakedness of the emperor is the
height of impropriety i suspect the
sheer degree to which we are asked to
engage in this simulation will go down
as the hallmark of the era
do you believe a commitment to diversity
should be crucial to the evaluation of a
candidate for a physics professorship
do you believe it's mission critical for
doctors to describe people in danger of
contracting certain diseases not as
vulnerable or disadvantaged but as
oppressed or made vulnerable or
disenfranchised
do you believe that being diverse does
not make an applicant to a selective
college or university more likely to be
admitted
in some circles these days you're
supposed to say you do
and recorder points out that there are
now physics positions that are being
listed at san diego state university
asking for people to show
engagement to service with
underrepresented populations within the
discipline
to have demonstrated knowledge of
barriers for underrepresented students
and faculty this is for physics he's
studying how objects move through space
and meanwhile the ama has released a
guide the american medical association
that urges practitioners to employ a
left-leaning glossary in pursuit of pub
public health equity
you're supposed to use equity-focused
language that acknowledges root causes
like instead of saying that low-income
people have a high level of coronary
artery disease you're supposed to say
quote
people underpaid and forced into poverty
as a result of banking policies real
estate developers gentrifying
neighborhoods and corporations weakening
the power of labor movements among
others have the highest level of
coronary artery disease in the united
states
this is all insane
okay but the insanity is the point it is
the feature not the bug if they can
force you to accept this what can't they
force you to accept now here's the thing
all of this is going to kill them they
don't understand it's going to destroy
them
on the ballot
okay the intersectional coalition will
not hold it turns out black people like
crime to be outside the city they don't
want to be subjected to crime
they don't care if more black criminals
go to jail so long as they are not
victimized by black criminals or white
criminals or any other criminals
it turns out that latino people don't
wish to be called latinx this is not of
high priority to them it turns out that
the vast majority of patients are not
interested in their doctors giving them
a disquisition on marxist economics they
want to know whether they have doubt
it turns out that this is not reality
but the left is pursuing a reality that
does not exist and they demand your
fealty they demand that you mirror
whatever their priorities are
and not only that that you then use the
power of law to enshrine their
priorities to reinforce their to cement
those priorities
i think you not only believe their bull
crap equity narrative but that you elect
progressive prosecutors who are going to
let people out on thousand dollars bail
to mow down children in a car
because racial equity is what is what
matters
this is what the left wants out of the
world they're not going to get it the
backlash is coming it's coming strong
and if the left wants it they are going
to get it and they're going to get it
good and hard
ross dude had a good piece in the new
york times today titled the diminishing
and democratic majority
he says if you're a democrat right now
you can tell yourself a reasonably
optimistic story even in the face of
disastrous midterm polling about what
the world after 2021 looks like for your
party
in this hopeful scenario inflation is a
challenge for a year but not a decade
much of the simmering public discontent
with the biden administration reflects
an exhaustion with covert era
abnormality
that's the optimistic tale
that would be enough to win democrats
back most of the political advantages
they've lost in the last year and go
back to worrying about the electoral
college but the more pessimistic
scenario is one in which most of these
hopes come to pass and others too but it
doesn't help them
okay this is the emerging republican
majority scenario says rastud in which
it turns out two of the big political
migrations of the trump era affluent
affluent suburbanites turning more
democratic working-class whites and then
latinos turning more republican it turns
out the first was temporary and
provisional and the second one is
permanent and accelerating
in this possible future it will become
clear glen youngkin's result in virginia
was a bellwether if there are a lot of
suburban voters will vote for moderate
seeming democrat over the trumpiest
republican but they'll swing back to the
gop if there's any excuse to do so
meanwhile
a lot of obama to trump voters in rural
white america or in latino areas of
florida and texas are culturally
alienated from contemporary
progressivism
which would mean that after biden
liberals should expect the deluge
so if republicans can hold themselves
back from being stupid which is always a
major question
then democrats are set to reap the
whirlwind
so keep doubling down guys truly keep
doubling down on this keep saying that
kyle rittenhouse is a white supremacist
and anyone who disagrees is evil and bad
please keep saying over and over that if
you want more criminals in prison
regardless of race this means that
you're a racist please over and over and
over again keep defending child
molesters as jojo like mark ruffalo keep
doing it keep doing it and see what it
brings you all right we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content coming up soon is the matt wall
show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be sure
to check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina her
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show